what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren and of course you should know
chris by now over at cosmic culture
throw 11 thunder we can finally talk
openly about this we couldn't after the
premiere because obviously
uh
we can't say any spoilers for it and
then in a spoiler free review obviously
you don't talk about spoilers but now
spoiler talk
they're coming they're spewing
coming out uh i'm looking at rotten
tomatoes right now the tomato mater is
68 i don't ever really care about that
it's really the audience score that i
look at um the people know what the
people want people right and it's 82
yeah and you know i know i know how a
lot of critics are just very cynical
people well a lot of critics impossible
to please a lot of these critics on the
tom the tomato meter are also not just
superhero critics like where we really
live
and a lot of movie critics don't like
superhero movies yeah it's they're super
heavy critical towards superheroes
yeah so it's like
this isn't cinema this is just a bunch
of people in tights so
yeah
yeah yeah um there are some but yeah the
good majority are you know it's weird
how there's that the
almost like a stigma against superhero
movement for sure but who cares we don't
care i don't care
[Laughter]
we like the superhero movies and the
audience scores 82 percent so it gets a
d from the critics over rotten tomatoes
the audience scores 82 and i think i saw
like sent a score today
was like uh like a b or something like
that as well where do you or something
how do you think that the audience score
reflects the movie
and that's with everything with all the
comparables with current
mindset of the mcu with current projects
come from the mcu and compared against
other thor projects what do you think
probably pretty accurately um
pretty accurately because there's like
the the the tears of fans right there is
the people like us and most people
watching this right now who really love
this stuff and you know we make videos
about it every day this is our job right
and and then the people who always come
to watch that's what they do you know
everyone right now they go on the
internet and they they want to hear this
stuff we're like level above right yeah
a little bit
um we're level above and then there's
the fans who you know are a little bit
more than the casual fans and then
there's the casual fans and i think this
kind of grabs all of them
i think it's pretty accurate but we're
going to talk about the good we're going
to talk about the bad because we finally
can we can talk about those post credits
we could talk about what sets up we
could talk about eternity which i loved
i truly loved eternity was such a cool
that was so cool and they kept that a
secret like
yeah they kept awesome
trying to find eternity a secret which
was really really cool so um
i love the movie
it's not my favorite marvel movie but
it's
uh i think
it's
right below ragnarok i think ragnarok
well ragnarok's one of your favorite
individual marvel films yeah right
exactly so it's i mean that's decent
coming i mean how many no it's a great
movie i i'm talking right now like it's
you know bad no it's definitely top 10
for me um
i i might have to see it you know a
couple more times you've already seen it
what four times
no three times three times three
yeah uh so but yeah let's just go ahead
and just start off with a bad so we can
end on a good note
um and people always like to hear like
well what did you actually find wrong
with it well let's ask ourselves
you know i i read comments
and i've seen a lot of people say they
loved it and a lot of people said it was
okay
and some of them that's a cat
that's a cat um some of them were saying
it's it's too funny like it's not
serious enough
and i could see how people think that
especially and i we said this actually
in our spoiler free review if you didn't
like ragnarok you're we're not gonna
like this film because it it just kind
of goes further than regular it kind of
came to a surprise to me i didn't
realize that this was a problem
until this movie i thought the good
majority and i mean like 95 of people
liked the switch from thor the first two
movies to ragnarok
right that was kind of my understanding
and then it's like oh no this one's
gonna be like ragnarok that was terrible
i liked the original thor's like i
didn't realize that that was an opinion
a lot of people shared it seemed like
everybody liked the new thor and i do i
love the way they've changed thor i
prefer it i prefer and and you're
completely right if you didn't love
ragnarok you're not going to like this
right and yes it's not it it deters
from
you know comic thor
definitely not a serious right but
that's okay but they tried serious and
it didn't really work
um
and basically like the the since
ragnarok
thor is kind of a comedic character and
we have a lot more to talk about but
first big thank you to athletic greens
for sponsoring this video if you are
trying to be more healthy if you're
trying to support your immune health if
you're looking to have more energy and
you're tired of taking all of those
pills athletic greens is for you i
wanted to see what all of the hype was
about so i tried athletic greens it
gives you over 75 high quality vitamins
minerals adaptogens and probiotics now
this is lifestyle friendly so you can
take this whether you're doing paleo
keto vegan dairy-free gluten-free you
can still take this and it's less than
three dollars a day which is pretty
cheap considering you're investing in
your health and the best part is it
actually tastes pretty dang good so if
you're looking to get healthier and toss
out the pills and the supplements
athletic greens makes it easy they're
going to give you a free one year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
cosmic again that is athleticgreens.com
cosmic take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
this is a comedy movie
i
no i don't either i i prefer it to the
first two i think it works a lot better
um
and i've i've heard some people i've
seen some comments they're like
you know marvel needs to understand that
not every movie can be a combination i'm
like well taiga with td's directing like
what did you expect like even he did
jojo rabbit the super serious sad nazi
movie and it's still kind of a comedy
like
yeah it's it's satire which shows
seriousness
and but it's it's a comedy yeah so it's
taika waititi it's exactly what i
expected from taikawa titi are there too
many jokes in it that's that's really a
matter of opinion like i can't sit here
and say yes there are no
there there's not because to me it was
fine i think i didn't i didn't think i
think if they were really and yeah some
are corny
but i still think they make you chuckle
even if they're stupid but that's an
important you can't laugh at people
that's an important point though because
i feel like a lot of people kind of miss
that joke because the corny jokes all
belong to jane
right thor jokes are the same they're
kind of good timing they're not forced
they're really funny but then jane's
jokes are all really kind of
like kind of corny like this is almost
cringy and awkward but that's the point
like that's exactly what they wanted to
do was she's the super serious nobel
prize winning scientist who's at the end
of her life possibly and all of a sudden
almost out of nowhere at no plan of her
own
has these hero powers she's dated a hero
she's aware of the avengers she knows
what it means to be a hero
and she's trying to go from a nerdy
professor
to a hero and that's the cringe of it is
the lions
she doesn't know them this is kind of
demonstrating how she's a different
character and a lot of people like
change lines were so cringe like
they were meant to be like if you feel
like they were cringed then they did
their job and i feel like some people
are kind of missing that aspect of jane
isn't a superhero personality she's a
nerdy scientist right yeah she hasn't
been she hasn't been alive for 1500
years
like thor has it just happened um
right and that's and they make that
clear
um valkyrie is like yeah like she's
great at saving lives but everything
else she sucks
they're pretty clear about that so
the bad could be i would say too many
jokes i personally
i like them all um because i like taika
with titi's style
of
directing i like the jokes um i think
korg is funny right i think works great
what's up i'm okay bro like i think that
stuff's funny when he gets like hitting
the head on the ship and he's like you
cool you okay i'm good bro like i find
that funny that's my pr that's my sense
of humor and it might not be some
people's sense of humor so i get that so
that could be bad now what i actually
thought was really bad and i didn't
personally like zeus
i i didn't like how they portrayed
omnipotent city um and of course they
changed that from the comics and the
comics it's not a place where all the
gods you know dwell and have a council
and stuff like that um
but i didn't like
and uh russell crowe is an amazing actor
obviously award-winning actor one of the
best out there one of probably one of
the best of all time gladiators classic
movie i didn't like
this zeus i don't like how he was
portrayed i thought it was weird um
was that because you don't like the idea
of all the gods kind of being selfish
and crazy or you just didn't like the
way that they
they kind of sent that in real quick and
then it was gone like what wasn't put
you off
i would have rather had
like a big mighty
zeus
good god
like
it was just really weird how
he just
you know wanted to talk about an orgy
and uh
you know oh let's talk about how many or
they did a competition of how many
humans were sacrificed and their names
and stuff like that and it's kind of
like oh yeah and you know valkyrie's
like yeah that's not good and even
though it's like oh yeah no this isn't
getting any better like
but thor it's like i almost feel like
thor
because you you know you always talk
about zeus and like greek mythology and
stuff and even thor is like oh the
mighty mighty zeus don't meet your
heroes yeah right exactly he's like you
know i base a lot off what i do off of
him you know lightning he's a superstar
but yeah it's it's a big mighty zeus
and
he is completely shifted from that so
maybe it's just oh we saw zeus was gonna
be the movie and i expected this and
then it was this and it threw me off but
i actually
[Music]
i just didn't i don't know i just i
still didn't like it it didn't sit well
with me the
the lack of caring the lack of
seriousness
um and he got serious like when he like
goes up to thor he's like a couple of
things he's like yeah i'm scared
he's like and you're scared but you're
scaring other people he's like calm down
so like at the same time i get that he's
like oh you know i gotta put on this
show for people so
okay but at the same time it's like dude
you're zeus yeah like tell everybody to
shut up like
i feel like my only argument against
that
and i would have loved to see zeus in
action and like a full power zeus not
like a clown juice but they're obviously
and you'll know and agree with this
trying to demonstrate that maybe gore is
right
oh for sure so it's like
i don't like the way they did that and
they could have done it a different way
that
and maybe zeus will show something up
because yeah we could talk about
post-credit scenes he's still alive and
maybe we will get some of that more
serious vengeful zeus um but no i get
what you're saying 100 like we see zeus
in the trailer and he's there and he's
big and he's got his lightning bolt and
then kind of pitters out from that like
that's that's the height of it right
yeah and um
i mean russell crowe wasn't in that good
shape for that role and i just i've de
in my mind based off of
greek statues and
pictures and all the stuff and and
studying it in college
i i picture the mighty mighty zeus
like like thor said but i mean he's
still large in stature big man
who holds his skirt up when he walks
down the stairs right no uh i'm like
okay but that's very greek right so i'm
like i get that and and people like what
is this accent i'm like it it's greeks
very great right
right someone's like he's a russian
accent i'm like no it's greek very very
great he's a greek god right so like i
get that i totally get that i just i
don't know i thought of something
different but
this could also go to the next bad point
of it not being serious enough
taiko at tt has a tendency with his
direction to
quickly go over serious things and kind
of laugh through it and that's an
oversimplification but
some people could think that that's what
happened in this film just way too many
jokes way too many goat laughs not
enough time to sit and really a lot of
good laughs not enough time to really
sit and digest the big things but
i also think we got some of the heaviest
scenes
in this movie like the scene where
it is funny because it's like both it's
like right thor's like i want to feel
crappy about something right and i think
that's you so it's like funny but at the
same time it's really really serious and
then all of a sudden she's like i have
cancer
yeah and it takes a real serious tone
right absolutely
and he talks about what star-lord told
him and it gets really serious and then
they go fight and then he come they're
back and it gets really really serious
where they all come back from the
bifrost thor loses stormbreaker and
she's reaching for the hammer and she's
so
just sick that she can't even get the
hammer next thing you know she's in the
hospital
and he's like yup just you know i'm
gonna head out i'm just gonna you know
get the children kill the bad guy i'll
be back and then it gets real serious
when she gets you know mad
that he's not that he's leaving without
her and he's like because i love you and
it goes to like to say i was like wow
that's actually really deep and it they
didn't you know really
pass through that very quickly they sat
in that scene for a little bit um
and at the end it got really really
serious with jane dying and with gore
dying
and i think it had to say of course
there were not as many serious moments
but i i think when the serious moments
hit they were pretty heavy
well you didn't even bring up the whole
gore storyline because you're the
thor conundrum which is kind of
bathed in jokes and lightheartedness
which is a huge coping mechanism that
people in real life i was gonna say yeah
this is that that's like that's oh i'm
around my ex who i kind of still have
feelings with and i'm wondering if they
still kind of have feelings for me
right so it's really weird like you you
you still rollerblading oh yeah once you
played you never fade but you gotta you
gotta you got a girlfriend oh no i don't
have time what about you oh i'm gonna go
check the city out i'll see you later
she leaves
all right that's all it's all
intentional right the comedy there and
it's realistic to a level it is no
entirely yeah right um
but
gore's parts were really serious and oh
my gosh was he awesome was he crazy
crazy scary
creepy yes uh
and it he was kind of quirky which i
kind of liked at the same time because
you are insane like at that point right
i mean absolutely you're out of your
mind
right yeah consumed by power and you
also have the you know yeah
the necro sword um
killing or like corrupting you so
the only problem i had with gore i think
was the ending so that was um my big
qualm i enjoyed everything about the
movie i think there was a perfect mix of
jokes to seriousness the seriousness is
very depth they're deep although brief
if you're paying attention and looking
for it there are a lot of
a lot of amazing tones there and it's a
very colorful film in that matter my
problem and i walked out of the first
viewing at the red carpet premiere with
one question mark and that was the
ending
and i'm still not sure
how i feel about it i guess they're
gonna have to show me
you know love and thunder is
eternity as a little girl potentially or
this little girl with some of eternity's
powers and and thor gorgeous gives up
like within two sentences that's why i
didn't want jane to die even though i
think we all knew that was going to
happen
part of me wanted to see jane and thor
together you know yeah so i don't know
that i loved the ending and obviously
with a marvel movie the ending is never
the ending there's always more story
coming and there's time to see what they
end up doing with it and maybe i'll be
like oh you know what
that's fine right but where we ended
how easily gorgeous gave up he's there
at the finish line with the wish and
he's like you know what
nah
yeah i just feel like that could have
been played out a little bit more
that was where i missed another 20
minutes of movie
right but before right yeah and it was a
short movie and maybe marvel's like hey
we've been having some long movies let's
do some shorter ones it's like
you kind of have them for a purpose to
be right
but i would have liked a little bit more
they should have planted that seed in
gore's ear earlier before the final
battle yeah kind of like thor would be
like you think this is what your
daughter wants like we're and like not
all gods are like this i'm here fighting
for my people right now like stuff like
that instead of just at the end in two
sentences right movie done
i do like what
uh how thor goes about it where he's
like you've won
and he's like
why would i spend a lot my last moments
with you that is i'm going to spend them
with her i like that part but it's
and it should have been more of a
struggle for gore like you said he kind
of just was like oh yeah okay
right it just should have been more of a
struggle
i like that he
when thor is holding jane he sees
himself holding his daughter
that should have been expanded upon like
we should have got and he's like ah like
he like he sees it and he's like oh this
is kind of like oh no this is like a
better thought
and it should have just been more of a
fight with him there
yeah um but it but it wasn't it was just
really quick that's yeah that i
it ended a bit quick for me
the entire movie was fast paced and i
liked that i was fine with that i could
have just used another 10 minutes at the
ending and i like i hadn't thought about
what you said where where thor's kind of
planting a seed throughout the movie
like he should have done i think and
then it would explain the quick turn
because you could even show a 30-second
scene where he's kind of thinking about
his daughter and he's pondering about it
you know what i can change positive
instead of negative right exactly
and i wish they would have done that
and then the whole ending with the
little girl that's more of a me and a
personality thing than than uh actual
bad writing the gore thing is really the
only issue
i just don't know what they're doing
with this little girl whether eternity's
actually in this little girl like they
showed that weird shadow scene where the
girl is eternity and goes inside her
body
right yeah so it's like where are we
going now well so i'm wondering and this
is really meant for another video
because i have to
think about this but i'm wondering
you know
is gore the first person ever to get to
eternity and that's the deal with
eternity eternity grants one wish to the
very first person
or is it eternity is always there
and whoever gets to eternity gets a wish
because eternity was gone at the end so
i'm sitting there going
maybe eternity is the wish
right and i will become your daughter is
inside of the power right um they picked
a fantastic actress to play the little
girl though let me say she's so cute
yeah she's so cute is that actually his
daughter
yeah i did not know that she cute little
girl and honestly that that's pretty
sweet i like that a lot
yeah and one of the the little thor
running yeah i knew that that was the
sun yeah yeah so
the eternity we'll come back to in a
different video but yeah we'll have to
but that is a really cool aspect of this
film that we mentioned at the beginning
they kept a secret the the visuals of
that character was stunning and i
couldn't believe i actually saw it that
was incredible and that that scene
that's like the gateway to all these
other entities that showed us like yo
they're out there oh they're there and
they're going to get to them and they're
right and there's a way to get to them
so
those are my qualms um i have a qualm
yeah i didn't like this
um and i like russell crowe
and i like the post credit scene
and
you know the connection to the mcu as a
whole i didn't need it for this movie
i'm okay watching a thor film
i feel like you know some other films
you you maybe need it in but this is so
entertaining on its own well thor's
really staple to the mcu right his
existence is a connection to the mcu so
well he i was gonna say he's already
been really established yeah he's
already really connected to a lot of
different people anyways so yeah but you
know we've already
while talking about these bad things
we've talked about the good things as
well
i love the fighting and how they film
the fighting like the whole scene on
that small
moon versus hilarious how they just run
into it so small and i show them walking
on it like it's just so small like i
just love it
um but that whole and i didn't think i
was gonna like this thing because it was
in black and white like i saw it in the
trailer and i was like oh i don't like
this
but it was awesome just like thor hits
gore and gore uses the sword to stop him
and you just see the shards of the moon
or the planet just kind of going up like
in some and the gravities you know you
can tell there's obviously less gravity
the the the planet or i know it's a mil
what condiment or asteroid i don't even
know what it is but we're to call them
space moon they were on right the space
thing they were on the space rock they
were on obviously doesn't have as much
gravity as planet does so it's like they
kind of move in slow motion as well as
like and then there's this one scene
with valkyrie where i don't know what
it's called it's a film style but
basically everything's like blacked out
you can just see the outline and but the
the lightning bolt is like bright gold
so it's like really cool to see
there's a lot of really cool stuff like
that that we saw in this movie
jane having her hammer at one point in
time she throws all the pieces away
monster comes up she stabs it with
basically just the handle and the pieces
come back and like crush its head and
it's like oh that was so cool i think
that was so much good fighting that was
something that was really cool and from
the trailer when she's fighting in
olympus and she like seemingly shoots
like ice shorts out of it i thought it
was ice shards at first everybody did
and they're like this is stupid why does
she get new powers like that was cool
that was a really good way of explaining
this ability how she's going to
manipulate the hammer she's working with
the hammer and you've said this several
several times the way that she comes to
become thor is yeah they could not have
done that yeah yeah that is where
perfect thor is like i need you to
promise me that is so that's so cool
and it's like she gets cancer somebody
on her calls to her that's so cool and
then it's like she's worthy because she
actually made thor worthy she helped
thor become worthy in the first movie
which makes her worthy it's like
that's super awesome and you know what
thus the
the love story i think is one of the
best that we've actually gotten in the
mcu it's i think it's a pretty deep died
but
maybe the exception of like peter and mj
but like at the same time and i'm not
trying to get this too much they're kids
like these are like
adults who theirs is more superficial
high school love like most people right
and this is really deep this is really
really deep you know right it's not
necessarily superficial and j and i'm
pretty sure mj's coming back and all
that oh for sure but there is a
complexity to they've been lovers they
broke up they are both lonely and one's
dying
there is that
realistic connection to the real world
that sometimes gets overlooked because
they're screaming goats in the
background but if you want to break it
apart there is
some real connection to emotion and to
problems with happiness in this film
yeah
no there really is i think there's a lot
of actual
as as much as you can get when you're
talking about a god dating a human i
think there's a lot of turned into a god
right exactly i think there is actually
a lot of realism inside of it emotions
because the emotions are real just you
can just swap thor being avenger with
thor working too much just like her
and i love how she's like i had to stay
at the office all day all night and he's
like i just sit here and clean up all
this she's like it's two plates
i said yeah that's a fun sequence when
they showed all of that like you're
seeing yeah they're trying to have
enough real stuff right but that's real
stuff that happens people work too hard
and don't spend enough time with their
spouse and you know what i mean play
more
yeah
people
um
so yeah i love the love story i lo you
know
to finish this i i liked the story a lot
i think the ending could have been
stronger yeah the ending is my big and
that's just because it's kind of we
don't know we don't know what's going to
come
this little girl i'm just actually
talking about the gore the gore part two
well that's true as well i that is
definitely a huge negative for me yeah
the gore part but like you said uh i
i think they have to start bringing in
the younger generation because heck five
years is gonna pass pretty soon and all
of a sudden they're gonna be you know
all these people are teenagers in real
life and then they're going to be
teenagers in the mcu yeah and 10 years
from now we'll have a new avengers team
you know
we'll do the young avengers but then
we'll have the new avengers with you
know kind of whoever's left and the
older generations the first generations
and then the newer people right with
spider-man and that's how it's gonna
work um
i would have
preferred jane to come back
in the comics thor calls her her
consciousness back into
and revives her and she beats cancer and
i i'm still i think that's coming in
four or five
i feel like it should i mean thor's
coming back it's straight up set it so
right and i heard some people in the
theater when i saw it last night they
were like
which store i'm like well it said thor
not the mighty thor that she did so
yeah
i know chris hemsworth is coming back
yeah i think she will come back as well
and honestly in the the post credits i
really enjoyed
the valhalla one i just thought it was
really nice that's
you know some people were like you hyped
up the credits i'm like i said one
was big and i said the other was nice
the other one and i really agree i think
they were both fantastic
but the valhalla one was like more of
like a nice really cool thing if we if
she doesn't come back
then we're good you know she's honest
that's awesome she that was awesome
she became a space viking and a god and
got into valhalla and the i mean
i mean the first one set up hercules i
mean
what else do you guys want come on
you're all sitting there waiting for
doom to show up
get some realistic expectations friends
galactus shows up opens his hand and
there's wolverine jumping
next to stanley and dead time
by the way jane totally said it's
thorben time into
thor's gear that's a hundred percent
what she said i figured out my
catchphrase it's thorben thorbentine
said it's perfect and thor said okay you
can die
yeah right so i'm not sure what the arc
for thor is gonna be
with a daughter now or a niece i guess
because she's like i love you uncle thor
but she has powers a knee slash eternal
slash
yeah one day it's like hey eternity can
you just come out for a second i need
your help gotta chat with you we need to
save the universe again right which is
what you are technically so
so
overall i
i don't know i think i give it like a
eight out of ten
i don't i hate raiding marvel movies i
do too that's why i'm like it's so hard
to do
it's it's very hard to do i think it was
a hit i don't think it was a miss i
think that they did what they wanted to
do
they told a good story if you didn't
love thor's comedic change i understand
why you didn't like this that's probably
yeah and that's the deciding factor you
either really liked the way they've
changed thor or you didn't and if you
did you really don't have a whole lot to
complain about here except maybe gore
dying that's my well that 20 second
round that's right and that's me too i
love the comedy i thought it was
hilarious i love
i love watching
thor
smash his hammer and i got a lot of that
both thor's right yeah so i'm okay with
that as well put the hammer down yeah
right
i i got a lot of that
in this so i was very very happy with
this movie and then there was a lot of
really good story plots inside of it
with jane and thor
and
you know gore's story was really cool
and that was done exceptionally well his
powers are really cool christian bale
was awesome
um
it's a very much a taiko with tt film
yeah the ending could have been stronger
but besides that i think it was a great
movie and the ending does lead to
something pretty
spectacular another thor movie coming
pretty much confirmed and
eternity is now hanging out with thor
potentially so that can oh yeah that
could only be good yeah but they did
introduce the cosmic entities we
actually saw them so that's that's also
pretty cool but hey let us know what you
guys think what did you think about the
movie um
yeah hit us with your true thoughts
because i've seen a lot of people say
they love it it's i've seen a lot of
people actually say they like it better
than ragnarok which yeah i i still got
to figure that out i don't know right
now yeah i i don't really know i say
like i think ragnarok's above it but i
still don't really know um
but because it had loki and the hulk but
that's we'll figure that out we'll do
another video
we're gonna have to do a video where we
just each pick a side and we just argue
why it's better we could do that yeah
but why why don't y'all let us know in
the comments below did you like ragnarok
more or love and thunder more or did you
not like either or you only liked one
you're just a sad person
right just just throw your comments uh
there and let us know how you feel uh
don't forget to like subscribe also
chris over at cosmic culture we're gonna
put them so they're over here
that is you we're gonna put all the
handles and stuff here so be sure to
give us some followers on all social
media and all that's good stuff so we
can all interact and talk with each
other and we'll catch you next time woof
you